Trascrizione: Eleonora Fantinel
Revisore: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Vi ricordate l'ultima volta che
siete stati in un museo?
Che tipo di esperienza avete vissuto?
Ne è valsa la pena pagare un biglietto
per entrare in quel luogo?
Ma soprattutto, quando pensiamo e parliamo
di musei, come ce li immaginiamo?
Spesso ce li immaginiamo come dei luoghi
legati al passato e un po’ polverosi,
un po’ bui, dove si raccolgono
tanti oggetti e dove si espongono
con piccole targhette spesso illeggibili,
chiamate per l’appunto didascalie.
A volte il museo...
In museo ci si stanca, i percorsi sono mal
segnalati e a volte si entra anche
solo per andare in caffetteria
o approfittare del bagno.
Chi di noi non lo ha fatto?
Pensiamoci.
Dire a qualcuno:
“La tua casa assomiglia a un museo.”
Beh, non è che gli stiamo facendo proprio
questo gran bel complimento.
Ma allora i musei sono ancora
così o stanno cambiando?
Io lavoro in un museo da 25 anni
e ho vissuto una trasformazione
che ha visto in tempi recenti i musei
diventare attori di importanti progetti
di rigenerazione sociale.
Sì, i musei stanno cambiando
e stanno cambiando rapidamente.
Ma come?
Il cambiamento più grande
a cui abbiamo assistito è stato
uno spostamento di interesse
dagli oggetti alle persone.
I musei sono soprattutto fatti
da persone che li hanno istituiti
pensandoli al servizio
della società e del suo sviluppo.
Certo, lo studio e la conservazione
del patrimonio culturale
rivestono un ruolo fondamentale,
ma queste conoscenze
devono anche permetterci di leggere
la contemporaneità da nuove prospettive.
Come diverse persone che lavorano
in questo ambito,
credo che il patrimonio culturale
del passato possa essere
una risorsa per riflettere
sulle grandi sfide dell’attualità,
dai cambiamenti climatici
ai diritti umani.
Viviamo un presente complesso,
fatto di diseguaglianze.
Attorno a questi temi è necessario
attivare un vero e proprio fronte
di resistenza culturale in favore
della democrazia e dei diritti civili.
Che cosa accadrebbe se, nel momento in cui
vogliamo interpretare un'opera d'arte
del passato, ci lasciassimo guidare
primariamente dalla volontà
di avere un impatto nel presente?
Un’opera d’arte - qui lancio una sfida
alla nostra storica dell’arte -
può aiutarci a riflettere su temi
attualmente apparentemente sensibili
come il genere,
la sessualità, i modelli familiari?
Certo. Partiamo da questi due ritratti,
Francesco Querini e Paola Priuli.
Francesco ha commissionato
questi due ritratti a Palma il Vecchio
in occasione del loro matrimonio, 1518.
L'artista però è morto prematuramente,
lasciandoli incompiuti.
Francesco è andato in bottega,
li ha presi, li ha portati a palazzo,
incrementando quindi le collezioni
dei Querini Stampalia,
una delle famiglie più antiche a Venezia.
Certo, queste due opere sono due
capolavori per la storia dell’arte,
ma proprio di fronte
a questi due capolavori
ci si potrebbe porre delle altre domande.
Per esempio, questi due giovani
si amavano veramente?
E qual era il ruolo del matrimonio
nella Venezia del Cinquecento?
È ancora così?
Certo, nell’epoca in cui sono stati
realizzati questi ritratti
il matrimonio era un obbligo
per la sopravvivenza della casata.
Erano infatti i genitori a stabilire
quale dei figli potesse sposarsi
e quali invece potevano essere destinati
alla vita pubblica,
alla carriera politica,
ecclesiastica, militare.
Le fanciulle, invece, che erano escluse
dai lasciti patrimoniali, erano
teoricamente libere di scegliere se
andare in convento o se sposarsi.
Certo è che gli alti costi
delle doti nuziali spingevano i genitori
a mandare le figlie in convento
anche contro la loro volontà.
Quindi questi giovani non potevano
scegliere la persona amata
con cui trascorrere
il resto della vita.
Il matrimonio era una scelta strategica
basata proprio su motivi economici,
di carattere estremamente economico.
Quindi, tornando alle nostre opere,
possiamo farci delle ulteriori domande.
Per esempio, ha ancora senso
parlare di famiglia tradizionale,
quando i modelli familiari
si sono così evoluti nel corso del tempo?
E ancora, oggi siamo liberi e libere
di esprimere i nostri sentimenti
quando andiamo
a ufficializzare queste unioni?
Ecco, chi lavora in ambito istituzionale
potrebbe imparare a fare un esercizio
importante e complesso, unlearning, ovvero
disimparare le abitudini consolidate,
come l’idea che un’opera d’arte possa solo
raccontarci la storia dell’arte
in senso stretto.
Babette ci ha appena fatto capire
che davanti a un’opera come questa
possiamo ragionare criticamente
su come i valori
che reggono un’istituzione
come il matrimonio
siano fortemente cambiati
nel tempo, riconoscendo come allora
e forse ancora oggi, questa istituzione
abbia avuto soprattutto un ruolo politico,
di controllo della sessualità, che esclude
diversi modelli affettivi e relazionali.
Oltretutto Venezia nel Settecento aveva
la fama di essere una città libertina,
ovvero in cui l’amore fra persone
dello stesso sesso poteva esprimersi.
Ed ecco che le collezioni
della Fondazione Querini Stampalia,
così come quelle
di molti musei in giro per il mondo,
possono aiutarci a farci capire come
l’amore fra persone dello stesso sesso
e la diversità di genere facciano
veramente parte della storia dell’umanità.
Spesso si sente parlare
di famiglia tradizionale
e l’idea che questa sia
alle radici della nostra identità.
Ma se andiamo a guardare indietro
nel tempo, ci rendiamo conto come
una propaganda forte
verso questo modello di famiglia in Italia
è stata fatta
durante il ventennio fascista
unitamente all’idea che alla donna
spettasse il compito della casa
mentre all’uomo quello del lavoro.
Ed ecco che i musei servono
a decostruire gli stereotipi,
a permetterci di andare indietro nel tempo
e a prendere coscienza di come
i concetti di genere, sessualità,
matrimonio, modelli familiari
siano sempre stati oggetto
di grosse trasformazioni culturali.
E quindi mi chiedo: in un museo,
possiamo rinunciare
a trattare tematiche di questo tipo,
avendo anche il coraggio di prendere
posizione nell’attualità, tenendo conto
delle fortissime battaglie
che dobbiamo compiere
dal punto di vista dei diritti
civili e dei diritti umani?
Eticamente non credo che sia possibile.
Ma soprattutto è ascoltando
i feedback dei visitatori in un museo
che mi sono resa conto
di come trattare questi temi
abbia veramente il potenziale di rendere
un’esperienza in un luogo di cultura
in un qualcosa di realmente trasformativo
per le persone.
Alla Fondazione Querini Stampalia
ci siamo messi in discussione
e abbiamo avviato un processo
di cambiamento e di innovazione.
Abbiamo innanzitutto ascoltato
i nostri pubblici
e poi ripensato il modo
di comunicare la collezione
attraverso un nuovo allestimento
e un nuovo apparato didascalico.
Vi posso assicurare
che è stata una bella sfida.
Essendo noi perlopiù
storiche dell’arte e quindi abituate
a un lessico accademico ricco di termini,
di descrizioni e di quant’altro,
la sfida era quella di essere sintetici,
senza però banalizzare,
non dare nulla per scontato e lavorare
sul coinvolgimento emotivo dei pubblici.
Volevamo parlare in modo diretto
al pubblico,
anzi a pubblici diversi,
senza escludere nessuno.
Ci siamo quindi lasciati alle spalle
il nostro ruolo da storiche dell’arte
e abbiamo iniziato a raccontare
delle storie nuove e diverse,
con un taglio
di carattere storico-sociale.
Abbiamo parlato
di welfare, di sostenibilità,
di matrimonio, di donne,
di istruzione, di genere,
ma addirittura
con delle pellicole trasparenti
alle finestre,
abbiamo raccontato
la storia degli invisibili,
ossia tutte quelle persone
che frequentavano il palazzo
ma che la storia dell’arte
normalmente dimentica:
il cuoco, il gondoliere,
l’amministratore, il cicisbeo,
l’amante e addirittura
le cagnoline di Andrea Querini.
E come abbiamo affrontato questo lavoro?
Innanzitutto abbiamo creato una squadra
di lavoro trasversale - storici dell’arte,
bibliotecari, archivisti - e lavorato
a stretto contatto con la direzione.
Abbiamo definito fin da subito
ruoli e responsabilità,
prediligendo il confronto continuo.
Abbiamo anche deciso quale doveva essere
il tono giusto di comunicazione,
proprio per evitare di usare
dei termini che fossero poco accessibili
o addirittura non inclusivi
e, per non perdere di vista l’obiettivo,
abbiamo stilato un piano interpretativo:
in ogni sala abbiamo definito
il tema da trattare,
le opere da approfondire
e le curiosità e gli aneddoti da citare.
Le opere d’arte, quindi, non venivano più
raccontate come dei singoli oggetti,
ma diventavano un pretesto per raccontare
delle storie nuove e diverse
e per dare al pubblico
la possibilità di riflettere
su temi sensibili della contemporaneità.
Ecco, non è che la storia dell’arte
e le competenze tecnico-scientifiche
non servano più, anzi.
Sono necessarie però nuove competenze,
perché la tecnologia da sola non basta
per creare
partecipazione e coinvolgimento.
Bisogna cambiare l’approccio al lavoro,
ma bisogna soprattutto cambiare
l’idea stessa di museo,
così come la comunità internazionale
ha fatto negli ultimi anni,
proponendo una nuova visione
che mette in primo piano
la società, la diversità, le persone.
Da qui bisogna partire
per costruire un nuovo inizio.
I musei sono cambiati e la cultura
può permetterci di riflettere
sulla complessità e sulle sfide
che viviamo da nuove prospettive,
avendo anche il coraggio di prendere
posizione a fronte di tematiche sensibili.
Sta a noi professionisti della cultura
continuare a lavorare
per cambiare il modo in cui
lavoriamo e per cambiare i musei,
per continuare a costruire
connessioni fra passato e presente
e costruire ponti fra mondi e culture
e nuove alleanze.
Sta a voi il compito però di crederci,
di continuare a visitare
i musei e la cultura
con l’aspettativa che questi
possano stupirvi, che possano emozionarvi,
che possano aiutarci
a costruire insieme un domani
che ci rappresenti una società più coesa.
Grazie.